to france now where the two candidates
in next sunday's presidential election
squared off in their only televised
debate the duel on wednesday was one of
the last chances for incumbent emmanuel
macron and his far-right challenger
marine le pen to sway voters and there
were some fiery exchanges
on the streets of paris it was billed as
france against france
and the big
a live tv duel between french president
emmanuel macron
and the woman who wants his job
far-right challenger marine le pen
and under the glare of the studio lights
the gloves were off
current president emmanuel macron
attacked marine le pen because of her
past dealings with
russia you depend on russian power you
depend on mr putin a few months after
saying that madame le pen you took out a
loan from a russian bank in 2015. first
czech russian bank the first czech
russian bank you don't talk to other
leaders you talk to your banker when
talking to russia this is the problem
le pen insisted she was independent of
moscow and returned to a key theme of
her campaign the rising cost of fuel and
essentials
i agreed on all the sanctions that were
taken against the oligarchs against the
banks
the only sanction that i disagree with
is the one blocking russian gas and oil
imports why
because i think that's not the right
method
this is not what will actually hurt
russia and above all it will hurt the
french people a lot
uh
the candidates clashed over macron's
economic track record over the last five
years and climate
change but on immigration and the
treatment of muslims in france the
candidates policies are far apart
i want to ban the hijab in public spaces
i'll say it in the clearest possible way
the veil is a uniform imposed by
islamists
you will create a civil war in the
housing projects madame le pen i'm being
honest what you're saying is very
serious
an opinion poll from a french
broadcaster found over half the viewers
surveyed thought macron was more
convincing in the debate
but french voters will have the last
word in sunday's runoff election
well for more let's cross over to dw
correspondent lisa lewis in paris lisa
how did this debate go down in france
well obviously each camp is saying that
candidate
came out on top when you look at you
know what people are saying across
social media and the people i've been
talking to there's uh though a some kind
of consensus that marine le pen when it
comes to her
style did better than five years ago you
know when we look back to 2017 she was
already facing imam makar in the runoff
debate a runoff vote and also in the
debate ahead of that vote and at the
time she literally crashed and got lost
in all the details and her dossiers this
time around marine le pen appeared a lot
calmer a lot more like a president
however when it comes to the facts uh
marco seems to have attacked her on
numerous dossier called her out said you
know that her figures didn't add up he
said that she was actually not the
candidate of increased spending power
that's what she's been trying to depict
herself as uh over the last past few
months and he also said that 80 percent
of the measures
that you know are part of her program
would mean that france would have to
leave the european union marine le pen
said no i don't want to leave the
european union i want to redesign it but
emma macron said this is not possible
with your current program as you said a
broadcaster did carry out a poll
two-thirds of those 650 people only that
were interrogated they said actually
that they thought that macro came out as
the clear winner it remains to be seen
if this will have an impact on the
election result you know in the past
historically speaking in france debates
have never really turned around things
but they can have a slight impact you
know pushing one candidate a bit up
another one a bit down in the polls
now macron accused le pen of having
strong ties to the kremlin what impact
do you think that accusation will make
on voters
that's true that's the one point where
he insisted on he talked about that
russia loan that was mentioned in the
report earlier on he also talked about
the fact that marina penn supported the
annexation of crimea in 2014 by saying
that the referendum that was actually
controversial on the international level
she recognized that referendum you know
that will certainly be invaders mind on
sunday when you look at polls on russia
and on putin vladimir putin from russia
the russian president and most french
people are saying that they are
concerned about you know that they're
shocked by the russian invasion in
ukraine and that they dislike vladimir
putin so it's likely that that will be
in their mind when they make their
choice uh on sunday here in france
uw correspondent lisa lewis there
reporting from paris thank you lisa
you